how are you doing
i'm doing so good it's good to see you
nice to see you
um so i just want to start with the most
important question
uh how many friends insisted they had to
visit you when you were filming
on this one
that's a good question quite a few
[Laughter]
quite a few we're like oh you know
nobody actually asked but yeah we joked
about it i joked about it with quite a
few friends
i was gonna say if if i knew you and you
were filming with lebron i'd be like
and i'll you know i need to be there
every day you know
don't you need something that i can
bring every day
completely uh true or false uh you did
this movie solely to get better tickets
at lakers games
hey
true okay
i will say my husband and i are huge um
our huge nba fans and we and we love
lebron um and that is something that we
realized after the fact so you know we
get the news it's huge
it's amazing i'm floored i can't believe
it my mind is blown that i'm going to be
a part of this
and then it's like and hold up
you know what i mean it was one of those
really uh lebron
uh has what we call a nice sneaker
collection he has a lot of shoes
did you get to walk away from this shoe
with any sneakers
you know what i feel like
i did you know a lot of the
i was in transition at the time that we
were shooting and i went straight from
shooting to toronto to shoot season
three of star trek discovery
um so some stuff got put in storage but
i think i did
yeah you should look out for those
because uh i've learned that sneakers
are what we call very popular
and uh yeah there's that whole sneaker
head collection type of thing right
that's right it's a part of the culture
yeah okay so
i love learning about the behind the
scenes on the making of any project
so what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of this
film
oh my that's a good question um i think
that well i don't know if it'll be
surprising but it definitely was
um it was very easy to become a family
i will say that you know we had we had
such
good um we just vibed
together really well all of us and and
the kids
um and and chris as well who plays malik
um
we we had a really good time together
and i think
people might not be surprised but maybe
they would be happy to know that we we
really enjoyed each other and had a good
time
when i was watching the film i couldn't
believe how many warner brothers
characters were in the background and
the fact that they got a clockwork
orange
or you know the the uh the penguin from
batman returns
what were some of the people that you
were like i cannot believe these people
are in the movie
oh my gosh honestly when when you got to
see the whole catalog
of warner brothers another thing i was
so impressed with
i was like this is genius because you
get to go through all of these people
all of these genres all of this i mean
i couldn't believe it especially once
they thread in the matrix i was like
what this is how amazing because the
matrix is my favorite movie
of all words yeah why wouldn't i that's
that's the one
that's probably the one that i that i
was most like what this
is so i have to ask are you looking
forward to the new one that's coming out
later this year
i'm such a lover of the original
um i am though i am looking forward to
it
i i hope to be pleasantly surprised
i i am a huge fan of the original and i
have to think that lana and everyone
would not have made another one unless
the script was awesome
that's what i'm hoping but listen i'm a
huge star trek fan i definitely want to
know
uh how things are going where are you in
the shoot for season four right now
um well we're just about done just about
done we just have a little bit more to
do
um and uh you know it's exciting as
captain now
that's a that's a big deal um to me and
you know i think to everybody who
watches and to the the history
of the franchise itself and i think it's
a really big deal to have a black woman
as captain be you know sort of cemented
um in that lineage um but it's it's uh
it's great i i there's a lot to come for
for season four a lot is coming
everybody's way
for season four i cannot wait and i
really mean it congratulations on
getting the captain's chair
that's [ __ ] sorry i almost i did
curse i'm like
thank you thank you for that long time
coming well earned though
in my opinion 100 congrats on everything
thank you so much for your time
thank you for yours